Augustine was a Christian philosopher
who lived in the fourth and fifth
century AD on the fringes of the rapidly
declining Roman Empire in the North
African town of hippo he served as
bishop for 35 years
proving popular and inspirational to his
largely uneducated and poor congregation
in his last days a Germanic tribe known
as the Vandals burnt hippo to the ground
destroyed the legions made off with a
town's young women but left Augustine's
Cathedral and library entirely untouched
out of respect for the elderly
philosophers achievements he matters to
us non-christians today because of what
he criticized about Rome its values and
its outlook and because Rome has so many
things in common with a modern West
especially the United States the Romans
believed in two things in particular one
earthly happiness they were on the whole
an optimistic lot the builders of the
pandu garv and the Coliseum had faith in
technology in the power of humans to
master themselves and in their ability
to control nature and plot for their own
happiness and satisfaction writers like
Cicero and Plutarch had a degree of
pride ambition and confidence in the
future which with some revisions
wouldn't be out of place in modern day
Palo Alto or the pages of Wired the
Romans were keen practitioners of what
we would now adays call self-help
training their audiences to greater
success and effectiveness in their eyes
the human-animal was something eminently
open to being perfected to adjust social
order for long periods the Romans
trusted that their society was marked by
justice giustizia
people of ambition and intelligence
could make it to the top the Army was
trusted to be meritocratic the capacity
to make money was held to reflect both
practical ability and also a degree of
inner virtue therefore showing off one's
wealth was deemed honourable in a point
of pride and fame was considered a
wholly respectable ideal Augustine
disagreed furiously with both of these
assumptions in his masterpiece the City
of God he dissected each of these two
points that human life could be
affected and societies were just in ways
that continue to prove relevant to us
today it was Augustine who came up with
the idea of original sin he proposed
that all humans not merely this or that
unfortunate example were crooked because
all of us are unwitting heirs to the
sins of Adam our sinful nature gives
rise to what Augustine called a libido
domain and II a desire to dominate which
is evident in a brutal blinkered
merciless way we treat others in the
world around us we cannot properly love
for we are constantly undermined by our
egoism and our pride our powers of
reasoning and understanding of fragile
in the extreme lust haunts our days and
nights we fail to understand ourselves
we chase phantoms with the set by
anxieties Augustine concluded his
assault by chiding all those
philosophers who in his words have
wished with amazing folly to be happy
here on earth and to achieve bliss by
their own efforts
it might sound depressing but it may
turn out to be a curious relief to be
told that our lives are awry not by
coincidence but by definition simply
because we're human and because nothing
human can ever be made entirely straight
we are creatures fated to Intuit virtue
in love while never quite being able to
secure them for ourselves our
relationships careers and countries are
necessarily not as we'd want them to be
it isn't anything specific we have done
the odds are simply stacked against us
from the start
Augustine Ian's pessimism takes off some
other pressure we might feel when we
slowly come to terms with the imperfect
nature of pretty much everything we do
and our we shouldn't rage or feel that
we've been persecuted or singled out for
undue punishment it's simply the human
condition the legacy of what we might as
well even if we don't believe in
Augustine's theology call original sin
Romans had in their most ambitious
moments thought themselves to be running
a meritocracy a society where those who
got to the top were deemed to have done
so on the back of their own virtues
after the Emperor Constantine's
conversion to Christianity the
philosopher Eusebius even proposed that
earthly power was God's instrument for
establishing Christianity on
so that the powerful in Rome were now
not just privileged but also blessed and
righteous in God's eyes
what arrogant boastful and cruel claims
responded Augustine there never was nor
ever could be justice in Rome or indeed
anywhere else on earth God didn't give
good people wealth and power and nor did
he necessarily condemn those who lacked
them Augustine distinguished between
what he called two cities the city of
men and the City of God
the latter was an ideal of the future a
heavenly paradise whether good would
finally dominate where power would be
properly allied to justice and where
virtue would reign but men could never
build such a city alone and should never
believe themselves capable of doing so
they were condemned to dwell only in the
city of men which was a pervasively
flawed society where money could never
accurately track virtue in Augustine's
formulation true justice has no
existence save in that Republic whose
founder and ruler is Christ again it may
sound bleak but it makes Augustine's
philosophy extremely generous towards
failure poverty and defeat our own and
that of others it's not for humans to
judge each other by outward markers of
success from this analysis flows a lack
of moral ISM and snobbery it's on duty
to be skeptical about power and generous
towards failure we don't need to be
Christians to be comforted by both these
points they are the religions universal
gifts to political philosophy and human
psychology they stand as permanent
reminders of some of the dangers and
cruelties of believing that life can be
made perfect or the poverty and
obscurity are reliable indicators of
Vice in a city of men
you